[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
Welcome to episode number 145
of the weekly "Google Cloud
Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel.
And as always, I'm here with
my colleague, Melanie Warrick.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm good, Mark.
Good to talk to you
again this week.
How was PAX?
MARK MANDEL: PAX was great.
PAX was wonderful.
PAX Dev was lovely.
PAX itself was great.
Got to catch up with
loads of friends.
It was really good.
MELANIE WARRICK: All the
gaming things last week.
MARK MANDEL: All
the gaming things.
MELANIE WARRICK: And last
week was a busy week.
There was GopherCon.
There was Burning Man.
It was a pretty busy week
and then a long weekend.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
which was good.
MELANIE WARRICK:
This week, we are
going to be speaking
with Dr. Mario
Lassnig, who is out of CERN.
He's joined us on the podcast at
one of our wonderful recordings
that we were able
to capture at Next.
And he joined us to
talk to us about ATLAS
and how ATLAS is using GCP.
So we're going to have that as
our interview for this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
really exciting stuff.
Thank you for setting
that up, Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, I'm glad we
were able to connect with him.
But as always, we will start
off with our cool things
of the week.
And this week's
question is, I'm not
familiar with Docker
or Kubernetes.
How can I get started with them?
MARK MANDEL: How
can you get started?
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
We were having a
good conversation
about how sometimes it's good to
revisit where to go, how to get
started with some of these
topics because a lot of people
are still new coming
into this space.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
Foundational stuff
is always important.
MELANIE WARRICK: Very much so.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So why don't we get stuck into
our cool things of the week.
It wouldn't be an
episode of the podcast
if it didn't talk
about Kubernetes.
So why don't we do that?
A couple of topics on
that one which I thought
were really cool--
Kubernetes released a
blog post recently talking
about how they use
machines basically
to do all their
testing, their CI,
to automate the
contributor experience.
I think this is really
cool if you've ever
been involved with a Kubernetes
project or even any open source
project.
You can tell that pull requests,
and continuous integration,
and anything like that can
get really complicated.
And Kubernetes is a big project.
So they go through all
the different projects
that they've either
written or used just
to basically manage this--
I don't know--
anarchistic duocracy
of open source that
makes things happen,
which is pretty exciting.
The good follow-up
from that, though,
is that up until recently,
all this infrastructure
has been run by Google Cloud.
But what we want to do is hand
that over to the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation.
So that's actually happened.
And what we've also done
is provided $9 million
in credits to allow
that infrastructure
to run on Google Cloud.
So it's going back over
to the Foundation, which
is really good.
I mean, Kubernetes is obviously
a mature open source project.
So they should have ownership
of that kind of stuff.
So I'm pretty
excited to see what
that's going to continue doing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, it looks
like they're using $9 million
in credits for over three years.
Part of that grant
will be dedicated
to funding scalability testing
with regular runs of around
150,000 containers across
5,000 virtual machines,
efforts like that that are
very much needed in the space.
But yes, this is a
good move in regards
to helping to make
the CNCF more capable
of supporting the
larger community.
So another thing we
wanted to mention
in terms of cool
things of the week
is that the product
that we provide,
called Cloud Talent Solution,
helps with job search
as well as for recruiters
to be able to find talent.
There's been an additional
functionality that
was added to it for veterans
who are transitioning out
of military service
into civilian life
and are looking for jobs.
It helps translate
their terminology
and what they're used to
from a military perspective
into a civilian resume
skillset perspective
without them having
to do it themselves.
So they don't have
to think about what
those words need to be from
the civilian side of the world.
They can just put in
their actual terminology
that they use regularly.
And the product itself will
do the translation for them
and help them surface
jobs that they're looking
for in the civilian market.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, this
looks really impressive.
It's being used currently
across FedEx, Encompass
Health, Siemens, as
well as through powering
veteran job sites like Get
Hired and other job boards
like CareerBuilder and
Mid-America Careers.
So I'm really happy to
see this initiative.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
And then another cool
thing of the week
that we want to mention
is John [? Foust, ?]
who's one of our team members,
has posted his first blog.
And it's specifically on Unity
for beginners from a beginner.
And I know, Mark, we did that
great podcast not too long ago
on Unity.
So you've got a lot of
knowledge in this space.
And it was good to see
John participate and share
what his experience has been.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really good.
He goes through several
different game engines,
why he particularly chose
Unity over the other ones,
and then gave a bit of a
general overview as well.
And he's going to
continue the series.
I think this is one
of just a beginning.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is.
It's a nice assessment,
and then the next steps
of what that's
going to look like.
The last cool thing of the
week that we want to mention
is that, for many of you
who researchers in the AI
and machine learning
space, you are
aware of the neural information
processing systems conference,
also known as NIPS.
This conference is
something that is regularly
attended by those researchers
and others in the community.
And it always
happens in December.
And we're actually going
to do a podcast about that
later this year.
Something to note is that
the registration for that
finally opened this week.
And within, what I understand,
about 15 minutes of it opening,
it sold out, which is
a near record for them.
Last year, it sold
out in two days.
So it's one of the more
established conferences
and well attended from the
community's perspective.
So it's impressive that
it's sold out-- maybe not
that surprising-- as
quickly as it did.
Something I wanted to give
a shout out, though, to it
is that they're
providing child care.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, lovely.
MELANIE WARRICK: Which
I think is wonderful.
And I know they
did that at ICML,
which is another regularly
attended conference.
So anyways, if you wanted
to go to this conference,
if you want to
learn more about it,
there's great
information online.
There's a lot of information
around the papers
that are going to be there.
In regards to registration,
if you wanted to attend,
my understanding is they may
be releasing more tickets later
on in the fall.
And you can always put
yourself on the wait list.
[SIZZLING]
MARK MANDEL: AI, it's
so hot right now.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is all
the things, all the things.
MARK MANDEL: It's
so hot right now.
[SIZZLING]
MELANIE WARRICK: Anyways.
Mark?
I think it's time for us to go
speak with Dr. Mario Lassnig.
On this week's podcast, we're
excited that we have Dr. Mario
Lassnig, who has
joined us from CERN,
and specifically the ATLAS
project over at CERN.
And we're recording this
podcast out of Next as we speak,
so you might hear
some fun ambient noise
in the background.
But yes, Mario, thank
you so much for joining.
MARIO LASSNIG: Oh, I'm
excited to be here.
Thanks for having me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Can you tell us a little
bit about who you are
and what you do over at CERN?
MARIO LASSNIG: I've joined
CERN roughly 12 years ago
as a PhD student back then.
I'm a software engineer.
And I've been working
on the data management
part of the ATLAS experiment.
And right now, I'm coordinating
the whole data management
activity for the
experiment, which
means the management of the
namespace, access to the files,
transferring
orchestrated activities
with a team of roughly 10
to 15 persons, distributed
from the institutes
in the United States
like Stanford Linear Accelerator
Laboratory, Brookhaven National
Lab, Rutherford Appleton
Laboratory in the UK,
also people at CERN, and then
from some other institutes
that contribute a lot.
MARK MANDEL: So for those people
who aren't familiar with CERN
and what CERN does,
can you give us
a high level what does CERN do?
MARIO LASSNIG: CERN is a
particle physics laboratory.
It was founded in 1954,
if I'm not mistaken.
MARK MANDEL:
Something around then.
MARIO LASSNIG: Yeah.
[LAUGHS] The buildings look
like that, yeah, I can tell you.
So what we have is a
accelerator complex,
where we try to figure out what
the constituent processes are
that make up our universe.
It's kind of like where
astronomy looks back
in the history of time, we
drill down like a microscope.
It's kind of two aspects
of the same thing.
So we have four experiments,
four large experiments,
attached at the Large
Hadron Collider.
And one of them is ATLAS.
That's where I'm working on.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
you're working on.
And can you tell us a little
bit more about what ATLAS is?
MARIO LASSNIG: Yeah, so ATLAS
is general purpose particle
detector.
You have to imagine that the
accelerator people are making
sure that the protons collide
in the center of the detector,
and then you have the
decaying particles
going through all the
layers of the detector.
We get hits in the detector.
Those are read out
by the electronics.
And then we try to figure
out from these hits what
the decaying particles
actually were.
So they deposit energy in the
detector in varying amounts,
those kinds of things.
MARK MANDEL: So what
kind of technology
do you need for this?
What do you do with this stuff?
MARIO LASSNIG: The actual
technology is all custom built.
So those are built
upon the experiences
from the previous
detectors that came.
So the original
particle detectors
were completely analog.
And now, we move to a more
digital way of reading out
these electronics.
You have to imagine the readout
from all the electronics
on the detector is roughly--
if I'm not mistaken--
1.5 petabytes per second.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
MARIO LASSNIG: And then this is
then triggered down in hardware
and later on through software.
And then we get event sizes,
roughly 2 to 8 megabytes
in size, depending
on what's going on,
if it's a proton or
[INAUDIBLE] event.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So my understanding
is you're using some of the
GCP products with the data
that you're managing.
What are some of the
products that you're using?
MARIO LASSNIG: We
completely integrated
the Google Cloud Storage and
the Google Compute Engine.
And the one thing that's
always missing in this picture
is that we also have
use of the G Suite.
MARK MANDEL: Good.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARIO LASSNIG: Because really,
it's a collaborative effort.
And by making sure that
everybody has access
to all the documents,
slides, and everything,
this is a well
[INAUDIBLE] thing.
MARK MANDEL: So you said there
was 400 petabytes of data
per second.
Is that all going into
Google Cloud Storage?
MARIO LASSNIG: No, we
couldn't afford that.
400 petabytes of data is
what we have in total.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
MARIO LASSNIG: And from the
detector, roughly 20% of that
is detector data.
The rest is assimilated data.
So we have
theoretical physicists
coming up with formulas.
They go to the
experimental physicists.
They make physics simulations.
And then we try to figure
out-- from the simulated data,
we compare it with real
data from the detector
to figure out if we'd have
any excess in the histograms
to see if a particular
property works out or not.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
So in terms of
Google Cloud Storage
in particular, how
are you using that?
MARIO LASSNIG: So we have our
internal data management system
that is basically tailored to
the way we have our computing
infrastructure built. We
have 170 data centers.
Those are all nationally
funded data centers.
So it's completely
heterogeneous.
So our system was
built to make sure
that all of these data centers
can talk to each other.
And now, we added the Google
Cloud Platform as an extension
to that.
So for the whole
infrastructure, it
looks like that the
Google source is just
another data center for us.
And we started out with the
S3 compatibility layer of GCS.
But then gradually,
due to authorization,
we moved to signed URLs.
And now we can use it just
like a regular web dev
storage, which is pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: That is super cool.
Are you just using
us for storage?
Or are you computing
stuff on us as well?
I think you said
you were using GCE?
MARIO LASSNIG: Yes.
So from the workflow
management point of view,
we are operating on a
slightly different scale.
So we have fewer users.
We roughly have 2,000 users.
But if one user pushes a
button and launches a job,
that job potentially
has to work through 50,
60 petabytes of data.
And this is all split up
into the smallest of jobs
across all these data centers.
And especially before
physics conferences,
you have contention.
So they will try to get
their histograms done
for their papers.
And that is where we then
spillover compute to GCE.
So we can fire up
VMs on GCE, ship
data that is needed from our
internal data centers into GCS,
do the computation, and then
shut it down when we're done.
MELANIE WARRICK: NIce.
And you're using
Kubernetes too as well?
MARIO LASSNIG: Yes.
So the CERN data center
is Kubernetes enabled now.
And in fact, one of the
things I saw at Next now
that was announced was
the Kubernetes on-premise.
So we're getting
in touch with the--
MELANIE WARRICK: A lot of
people are excited about that.
MARIO LASSNIG: Yes,
this is super cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
specifically are you
excited about regard
to that for you?
MARIO LASSNIG: From the
application point of view,
this means that we can scale
out on a much easier level.
Because procurement is
very much hardwired.
So we have to make resource
requests like that.
But if we can say we
scale out when we need it,
then this gives us
much more flexibility.
MELANIE WARRICK: When you were
making decisions on the tools
to use, what were some
of the reasons for why
you decided on GCP
or the products
that you specifically chose?
MARIO LASSNIG: For us,
the most important part
was the openness
and the flexibility
that we get from that.
When we tried to
do this internally,
we came up with our own
homegrown solutions.
And then suddenly, you start
to have this second order
effect, which means you don't
have any developers coming
in new into the collaboration or
leaving the collaboration that
actually know how
to operate this.
But when you focus on
tools that are basically
industry standard, you
open up your development
and engineering pool to a lot
of people who can help you out.
And this is a very much
understated problem
that we can solve with that.
So from the technology itself,
it's straightforward for us.
MARK MANDEL: That's nice.
And when you built this
integrated solution,
do your scientists need to know
that they're running on GCP
or they're running
on your data centers?
MARIO LASSNIG: Yeah.
We actually don't
want them to know.
For the user, what they
do is to make selections
on physics properties.
So eventually, they
say, give me this region
with this and that property.
And then it comes
out, OK, you need
to run across these
one million files.
They're all over the place.
And then you end up with
a selection of these files
on content of data centers.
And then we just take
that part, ship it to GCS,
and do the computation on GCP.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Any lessons learned
along the way
from building out
with these tools?
MARIO LASSNIG: So the
most important thing
for me personally was to
handle the authorization.
Because the scientists are
all integrated in a-- we
have the US, Europe, Asia in
a single unified federated
authorization namespace.
And to get the credentials
from a single scientist
into the controlled budgeted
environment on the Google Cloud
Platform, that was a bit
tricky to figure out.
So we're happy with that.
For example, when we were
still using the S3 layer,
we had to give out the S3
access keys to the people.
And suddenly, there could be
a single scientist saying,
OK, I need to run
the [INAUDIBLE],,
and by accident, it
starts to run on GCE.
And suddenly, you rack up a bill
of things that you can't pay.
So that was one of the reasons
we had to really make sure
that the authorization
and authentication were
real-- yeah.
MARK MANDEL: How did
you solve that then?
MARIO LASSNIG: We have
a authorization layer
built into our data
management system, Rucio.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
In terms of the research
that you're doing with ATLAS,
how is that research used
by the broader community?
MARIO LASSNIG: So
we've always tried
to build our data management
products on top of the computer
science literature.
So it's not like we
went ahead and just did
something radically different.
And this also shows
because we managed
to get quite a lot
of PhDs out of it
with master's students working
on it who were regularly
publishing papers just on the
way we do our data management.
And this is much appreciated
in the community.
On the other hand, this is
not only about research.
It's also of making the
product generally available.
So if you go to GitHub, you
can grab a copy of Rucio
and try it out for yourself
if you have a data center.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
And any specific groups that
you collaborate with that you'd
be able to share?
I know you collaborate
with a lot of groups,
but some that come to mind.
MARIO LASSNIG: So
from the universities
we work with very closely
is the University of Oslo
in Norway, Wuppertal in Germany,
and Innsbruck in Austria.
And then from the larger
research laboratories,
it's mostly Brookhaven
National Lab in New York,
and the University of
Texas at Arlington.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, OK, great.
MARK MANDEL: I'd love to
hear more about the GitHub
side of things.
How open is this data?
Or how open is this process?
Is there stuff that
people can play with or--
MARIO LASSNIG: Yeah.
So even though
this is essentially
principally a
CERN-led project, we
have a completely open
Apache-licensed product.
So you can just go there.
If you want to try it out,
you grab the Docker images.
If you find something
that you want to fix
or you want to improve, just
file a ticket on GitHub,
and either prod the
developers or do it yourself.
And you just submit it.
MARK MANDEL: And is this for
general just data processing?
Or is it specific
for CERN data sets?
I'm guessing people don't have
access to CERN's data sets.
MARIO LASSNIG: So this is
really the software itself.
And if you have a data
management problem,
this is most likely a
useful solution for you.
If you want to get access to
the experiment data itself,
you have to be a member
of the collaboration
because what we don't want is
that people start to get access
to intermediary data,
and suddenly, you
get an excited
journalist proclaiming
some discovery that was not
confirmed by the collaboration.
So we have to be very careful
also with data privacy.
MELANIE WARRICK: How does
somebody become a member?
MARIO LASSNIG: You have
to join an institute that
is a collaboration member.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That makes sense.
Well, what are some
of the future plans
you have for development
of your platform?
MARIO LASSNIG: So our
platform is currently
being evaluated by a couple of
experiments, namely, the Square
Kilometre Array.
So that's a really big
radio astronomy project.
The Deep Underground Neutrino
Experiment, DUNE, at Fermilab.
LIGO is also
evaluating and a couple
of other high energy particle
physics experiments, CMS.
So what we're are trying to do
is we're trying to branch out,
essentially, from ATLAS
into all these communities.
We're trying to offer them a
service, a product, and support
community, where
everybody can contribute.
This means now we have to make
sure that the product itself
can tie into all the
intricacies and problems
that these communities
have and try
to solve them in a generic way.
The way the system is
built is very modular.
So it's really not
specific to ATLAS itself.
So that's why we had very good
success in the early evaluation
stages with the
other experiments.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARIO LASSNIG: I'm
really happy about that.
MARK MANDEL: Are other
team's inside CERN also using
the same platform?
MARIO LASSNIG: It's
essentially a single instance
that posts the whole thing.
MARK MANDEL: The whole thing.
MARIO LASSNIG: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: What are the
quirks of the science community
with regards to their data when
compared to a regular business
enterprise?
MARIO LASSNIG: [LAUGHS] They
start to get very cautious when
you mention the word
"commercial platform" because
for a scientist,
if they don't have
full control over
their data, they
start to get very, very anxious.
So it was our job to ensure that
when they want to process data,
when they want to store data to
ensure that even if it's moved
to a commercial platform
that their data is secure,
but also, that they still
retain full ownership
and control of the data.
It's more of a sociological
than a technological problem.
But you have to make sure that
you break this mindset a bit
and tell them you can trust
us, the technology is secure,
and we're there
for the scientists
and not for the
commercial company.
That's our mantra.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know we're
doing this interview at Next.
And you were here
to speak at Next.
What did you talk about?
MARIO LASSNIG: Yeah,
exactly about this topic.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, yeah?
MARIO LASSNIG: It was a shared
session, scientific computing
with Google Cloud Platform.
The first half was from
the Pangaea Project
that did Earth and ocean and
atmospheric sciences modeling
on interactive notebooks.
And then the second
half, I spoke
about the way we integrated
GCP into our ATLAS computing
infrastructure.
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
Was the interactive notebooks
Jupyter by any chance?
MARIO LASSNIG: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Yeah.
We did a podcast on the
Project Jupyter a while ago.
Yeah, I think it was 122.
Anyways, any exciting
things that you've
seen at Next while you've been
here, outside of the on-prem?
MARIO LASSNIG: Yeah, I've been
speaking to a lot of people.
So in fact, I've
actually spent most
of my time talking
to people personally,
getting in touch with
the network people.
Because one of the things
that's very important
for us is to get
the data as quickly
as possible from
our data centers
into GCS, which meant we have to
jump from the National Research
and Education Networks
through the peering points
into the Google network.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, wow.
MARIO LASSNIG: If we
do that, actually,
we can saturate our
data center output.
MARK MANDEL: How fun.
Actually, so that's
an interesting point.
So you peer with Google
Cloud Platform as well?
MARIO LASSNIG: Yes.
There are a couple of
peering points in the US.
And the ones we tried out
was, if I'm not mistaken,
South Carolina and Brussels.
MARK MANDEL: For
those people who
may not know what
peering is, can you
talk a little bit about that?
MARIO LASSNIG: It's
essentially the private network
that is directly connected
to the Google network.
MARK MANDEL: Now,
that makes a lot
sense given the amount of data
that you're shifting around.
MARIO LASSNIG: Yeah, we
don't want to get limited
by public networks.
So if we get throughputs that
are 150 megabytes per second,
we're going to wait a long time.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
cool, and understandable,
like you said.
Well, great.
Anything else that
you wanted to share
with us before we let you go?
MARIO LASSNIG: There
will be a Rucio community
workshop some time in Autumn.
We still have to define
the time and place.
We had a pretty successful
one in March this year.
But due to the uptake
of the community,
we thought maybe we
will make a second one.
And now, we will invite
again all the developers
from the other experiments.
We'll open it up even more.
We're trying to branch out
of our single experiment
installation and try to get
even more people on board.
MARK MANDEL: Are
you actively looking
for contributors and
people to get involved?
MARIO LASSNIG: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Where can they go if they
want to get involved?
MARIO LASSNIG: GitHub.com/Rucio.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Hey, there you go.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, great.
Well, Mario, thank you so
much for joining us today.
MARIO LASSNIG: It
was my pleasure.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you again, Mario.
We really appreciate you
coming on to the podcast
and talking to us about ATLAS.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, super
cool, super cool stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So Mark, I'm not
familiar with Docker
or Kubernetes?
Where can I start
to learn about them?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I want to talk about this
a little bit more too
because I think, as people
who work in technology,
we have a tendency to want to
talk about the new shiny thing
all the time.
Sometimes I think it's
actually very important
to go back to the foundational
aspects of what we're building
on top of, because
sometimes people haven't got
to the new shiny things yet.
And that's totally fair enough.
So if people are like, oh,
Docker and Kubernetes, maybe
this seems really complicated,
or where do I get started,
the ecosystem has grown so
much, I don't know where to go,
I just wanted to provide some
guidance and some resources
that are available.
So if you're thinking about
getting involved with Docker
and Kubernetes,
we definitely say
get started feeling
comfortable with Docker.
So there is Docker's
official Getting
Started Guide on their
website, which we'll
link to in the show
notes, which is great,
gives you great step-by-step
instructions on how
to get started
building containers,
pushing things to registries,
that kind of stuff,
just getting familiar with that
vocabulary and that toolchain.
I think that's a
really great start.
There's a website as
well called Katacoda.
They also have a free
interactive Docker course
that I also really like.
So if you don't want
to install any tools,
or just want to just
try it in the browser,
basically, they have a
series of all kinds of stuff.
They have-- oh
wow, there's a lot.
There's, I'm going to
say, at least about 15
different things
just there waiting
for you to play with it.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's nice that
it's inside the browser too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, if
you're like, OK, cool,
I'm feeling more
comfortable with Docker,
I want to get started
with Kubernetes,
my favorite place
honestly to start
is there's a comic
from the GKE team.
I think it's both amazing,
gorgeous, and just hilarious.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
are a fan of that comic.
MARK MANDEL: I love this comic.
MELANIE WARRICK: You do.
MARK MANDEL: I think
it's so well done.
And I think the wonderful thing
is you can read the comic.
It can give you some
ideas of the reasons
and the basic philosophies
behind Kubernetes.
And then it just runs straight
into an interactive tutorial
that you can just
pick up and run with,
which I think is great too.
And speaking of
interactive tutorials,
also, one of my favorite
sites, Katacoda,
has a free interactive
Kubernetes course
as well, which is just another
lovely place to get started.
So it's got stuff in there
even around lodging clusters,
if that's something
you might want to do,
but even just things like just
starting to deploy containers,
doing simple web apps,
just getting started
with really simple
stuff to just get going
and even some of the more
complicated things as well.
So it's a really this
way of getting going,
and again, nice
safe environment.
It's online.
It's in a browser.
You don't have to
install anything
or do anything special
that way either.
MELANIE WARRICK:
When you started out
on this, what were some of
the resources that you used?
MARK MANDEL: That's a
really good question.
So I started three years ago
before Kubernetes was 1.0.
So it was a very
different landscape.
So I kind of grew
up with the project.
So I have certain history.
So people who are new to it,
I feel like things like this,
I think, are really
good because I
had a very different
upbringing in this ecosystem.
MELANIE WARRICK: It lowers
the barriers a little bit,
the resources that
you're recommending.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
Mark, where are you going to be?
Where are you going this month?
MARK MANDEL: Where am
I going this month?
Where aren't I going this month?
MELANIE WARRICK: What haven't
we talked about already?
MARK MANDEL: I think
we've talked about it.
But just as a reminder, I'll
be at Tokyo Next next week
basically.
So pretty excited about that.
Going to be doing the inside
event, which is the game event.
They're talking about that.
And then both of us will
also be at Strange Loop
shortly thereafter as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
And you're speaking
at Tokyo Next.
Is that right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I'm doing
the inside event, which
is the game-specific event.
So I'll be speaking at that.
And I'll be hanging
around as well.
I might be doing some
other couple of things.
Yeah.
What are you doing now?
You're traveling too?
MELANIE WARRICK: I am traveling.
I'm going to be in South
Africa near Cape Town
at Deep Learning
Indaba, the conference--
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--that is specifically
machine-learning
focused, deep-learning
focused in that area.
We're going to be talking to
a number of people who are
going to be at the conference.
And we'll be including some
of that on the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, I'm looking forward
to hearing that content.
MELANIE WARRICK: Me, too.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Melanie, thank you
for joining me yet again
on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]